und es geht um unseren beiden lieblings
figur frau stark zimmermann ist
digitalisierung kommt nicht voran die
bundesregierung von daher weist dem
also hier zu wenig sendezeit hier übrig
freund karl lauterbach meine these heute
diejenige die sozusagen
einen bärendienst das wahrscheinlich die
die gehälter für die pflegekräfte es
da die die die glas die figur ist im
abend ist nämlich dass karl lauterbach
lassen die letzte frage die ich nämlich
menschen auch nicht mehr ernst nehmen
fehlen pflegekräfte es gibt so viel zu
werden und mir kommt das so ein bisschen
solche karl lauterbach werden und wie
noch habe zu meiner these und karl
bereich von verteidigung man eine
vor wie so ein adhs kind was immer dann
tun in diesem haus ich mir wünsche dass
lauterbach gibt es denn irgendeine
geflecht gestimmt dass ich rede jetzt
komme ich darauf
ein teil der zeit den aufwendet in
wenn es mal keine aufmerksamkeit und
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
chance dass er zurücktreten muss
vom ukraine krieg ich meine sie hat ja
lauterbach ist ja eine der stimmen der
weihnachten irgendwas macht wie das er
talkshows panik zu verbreiten aufwendet
es liegt da ist sie die eindeutig auf
überhaupt also wenn er sich so weiter
regierung auch nach zweieinhalb jahren
gar nicht wie mutter wieder rennt wie
zulässig dass leute anderer meinung sind
drohen ab anime und nach all den neuen
fällt und mich jeden tag wahnsinnig
man den eindruck den man hat ausdrücken
für die zeit in seinem haus das ist
als ich und das halte ich für zulässig
machen ob später wegen der neuen
erkenntnissen immer noch nach harten
soll ohne dass es justiziabel wird also
variante sehe keinen grund warum man
weniger wärme ist da gibt es auch
und insofern für mich im moment die
maßnahmen was heißt eine der stimmen
zurücktreten was auch wenn die bürger
weniger schlacht sein aber das hilft
ich sage mein kind vor sich zu formen
sich wünschen
die ich finden kann er hat nicht mehr
vielleicht der bevölkerung und auch den
entscheidende frage der ukraine kriegt
eigentlich versteht sich niemand so sehr
nein so nicht aber natürlich wenn er
alle am sträußchen könnte das ignorieren
da ist frau stark zimmermann schon die
pflegekräften mehr als nur panik zu
auf die panikmache ist er keiner kann es
richtige ich wollte aber eigentlich
sie tradition mit der killer variante zu
sagen dass diese regierung ist an den
völlig das vertrauen der ministerin
so gut und vor knapp zwei stunden habe
verbreiten und die menschen im gleichen
kommen zeugt nicht von
alter nenne ihn seit er von dem killer
minister des bundeskanzlers verliert
ich mich beim schlitteln aufgeregt da
schon an den sollbruchstellen angekommen
erschließen es gab doch den den dem
virus gesprochen hat für mich nur noch
hat er nämlich getwittert zitat in den
wenn er die bevölkerung in in erregung
also eine koalition zwischen dieser spd
griechischen finanzminister der uns alle
killer karl das muss ich sagen weil sie
usa ist eine neue variante aufgetreten
versetzt ohne lösungen zu bieten wenn er
in aufrufes ihre fragen ist es auch ist
und in meinen anderen parteien wird
jetzt war es so daneben das ist eines
die deutlich anstecken als omikron baa2
immer finde ich immer fragiler und ich
genau so kommt mir das vor dass er für
tatsächlich
ministers vollkommen unwürdig ein
diese zeit so eingesetzt wird und
weiterhin übersteigert in talkshows
zu sein scheint niemand hört das gerne
vermisse aber eine nach vorne drängende
irgendwann ist die karl zeit vorbei wenn
minister muss eine art von konsens
aber es ist so dass corona virus bleibt
union die dann sagt mit denen geht es
dringt ohne die arbeit im ministerium zu
herstellen wollen dass er ein land auch
er so weitermacht glaube ich früher als
nicht mehr wir leben ja nicht in
unberechenbar mal wieder eine warnung
machen wenn er nachweisen kann dass da
einfachen zeiten wir müssen das machen
später auch ihr denn dazu hat oder eine
psychologisch interpretiert dass erst
wichtige arbeiten der liegen bleiben
nach dem lauterbach erst vor wenigen
ganz dicke frau und er muss motorrad
mein eindruck ist dass herr merz auch
die hand nimmt dass er es in die
lamprecht laut einiger
tagen prognostizierte dass wir im herbst
dann kommt schon so ein moment wo ein
kein wert darauf legt in dieser
richtige richtung führt aber nicht
eine klar variante kriegen könnten
bundeskanzler sich die frage steht nützt
also ich finde dass der gesamte spd teil
situation mit diesem krieg kanzler zu
laufend erschreckt und in panik versetzt
aufgrund seiner evidenz vereinbarung war
er mir noch oder schadet er mir und der
und jetzt sind die leute gerade ein
werden also ein bisschen leisetreter
bisschen freigelassen worden sie müssen
ihm dann nicht nur virologe jonas
risch kommt mir die union schon vor
der bundesregierung keine gute figur aus
punkt ist noch nicht erreicht aber wir
keine maske mehr tragen überall und er
woran liegt das ich habe ehrlich sagt
schmidt-chanasit und henrik strikt
werden irgendwann dahin kommen und dann
kommt karl lauterbach um die ecke wie
roberto ja ich hab's ja tut der kann
panikmache vor was wir in deutschland
gänzlich anderen eindruck wenn sie sich
wird man sehen ob karl lauterbach lernt
kann denn der minister der diesen
bisher noch nicht so viel fordert und
brauchen ist schluss mit der panikmache
anschauen wie wie im bundestag
sich als ja der konnte jetzt sechs
oder ob er weiterhin in die talkshows
schluss mit den lauten tönen und
diskutiert wird wo auch friedrich merz
prozent rentenerhöhung konnte er
lockerungen kein markt keine massen
verkünden konnte aber da eigentlich
die punkte macht sie haben vorhin über
deswegen mein wunsch karl lauterbach
drängt er lernt nicht ich glaube dass es
die 100 milliarden gesprochen
nichts denn keiner hat seinen urlaub war
pflicht mehr zugestimmt hat gleich im
in diesem fall haben uns mit dem
soll endlich karl lauterbach werden
sondervermögen wo wir ganz klar unsere
typischen kartenhaus fall zu tun wenn du
aber von daher ist er da genau dich alte
gleichen atemzug sagen aber im herbst
punkte gemacht haben in denen wir auch
eine karte herausschießt bricht alles
profi ist er da profit profi genug die
gesagt haben das sind die sechs
wird es wieder ganz fürchterlich
zusammen wenn man karl lauterbach
nina dein wunsch ist mein wunsch und
kriterien warum wir dann von denen wir
entweder oder dann muss er sich doch
der restliche spd teil ist tatsächlich
zurückziehen würde als bundeskanzler
entscheiden ich bin gegen die lockerung
hier ist seit heute tatsächlich und
abhängig machen dass wir dann auch
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zum
zustimmen und am schluss ist die cdu
stellt sich die frage warum ist
der masten pflicht gegen die aufgabe
weglaufen gleichwohl ist es so muss man
gemeinsamer wunsch wirklich nur nur
dagegen setzte es aber nicht durch dann
eigentlich frau lambrecht noch
deutschlands eine partei die immer auch
ministerin und andere
realistisch sehen wir sind derzeit in
zustimmen denn was karl lauterbach am
muss er dafür antreten dann muss sagen
kriegszeiten da können jetzt auch nicht
regieren will und deren
ich stimme dem gesetzentwurf des fdp
alle paar wochen irgendwelche minister
sonntag im bild am sonntag immerhin also
selbstverständnis es auch ist zu
ministers nicht zu aus diesem grund weil
zurücktreten und dann neue rein kommen
regieren und von daher sollte es da zu
wenn dann müsste es eine erklärung
abgeliefert hat das war glaube ich etwas
im herbst kommt ein ganz schrecklicher
einem koalitionspläne stehen wir
fordert geben dass lambrecht
virus aber nicht dem zustimmen und dann
wo er mit einer schlagzeile gerechnet
natürlich
zurücktreten soll eben noch gesagt dass
wollte sagen wenn der bundeskanzler im
hat es wurde zwar eine andere dann aber
lambrecht so ich habe nicht gesagt dass
hinterher damit er wieder mal
zurückzieht stellt sich sofort die frage
lamprecht zurücktreten soll das völlig
getroffen
ich habe es einfach so medien versetzen
warum ist verdammt ministerin wenn du
was gesagt hat den schuss nicht gehört
deplatziert ist und ich fand frau
also ich glaube da ist jetzt der zeit
lambrecht von anfang an als ministerin
einen gehen lässt
dass er glaubt ich muss jeweils bieten
er schießt ja laufend selbst zu
jetzt nicht unbedingt die zeit einer
deswegen rede ich mal von der killer
müssen andere mitgehen und dann hast
erschließen
da nicht wirklich an geeigneter position
darauf will auf sich aufmerksam machen
variante das funktioniert bei bild bild
selbstbeschäftigung in einer enquete
gleich eine richtige vettel ja ist
am sonntag sehr gut und dann haben die
gestellt ich kenne sie noch als
kommission die am schluss vielleicht
und das war wieder mal so ein zitat von
bleibt da auch noch anne spiegel ist
sowieso nichts zu entscheiden hat ich
der man genau wusste was es auslöst und
die schlagzeile und ich bin wieder da
staatssekretär im finanzministerium da
doch in urlaub gefahren ist lang aber
finde dass wir wenn wir ein strich
war es ehrlich gesagt ähnlichem
auf den titelseiten und kommen in die
das ist unverantwortlich ehrlich gesagt
frau lambrich das gegen die wachen dass
drunter machen den letzten zwei jahren
nächste runde der talkshows wo ich ja
ausschließlich können sie eine anekdote
nach dem auftritt ging es nicht anders
gut durch diese corona krise
so ein minister nicht mehr tragbar aber
immer unbedingt hinwill ich hätte mir
mit uns teilen
ist ja auch selber zurückgetreten ja von
durchgekommen sind sowohl wirtschaftlich
wie oft haben wir da schon gesagt er
im finanzausschuss wird das ist das denn
nicht gedacht dass es so bleibt ist ich
macht sie einmal wieder aber
aber auch bei den krankheits und
ihrer partei zurück getreten worden
unverantwortlich ist ja aus meiner sicht
bin mittlerweile davon überzeugt
ja nicht öffentliche sitzung aber wenn
haben wir mal so rose aber die spd tritt
auch dass er ja auch dem anliegen einen
todesfällen es hat vieles aufgedeckt was
gewinnen nur mittlerweile müsste er doch
sie sich sozusagen entlang hangeln
bärendienst erweist weil erstens will
wir noch verbessern müssen insbesondere
doch niemanden zurück wenn da müssten
müssen an ihrem sprechzettel dann wird
den schuss gehört haben es müssen auch
im gesundheitsbereich aber ich habe da
keiner mehr hören zweitens genau das
sie alle zurücktreten fast ausnahmslos
es halt immer schon schwierig und man
vernünftige leute geben eine
erkennt das weiß der kommunikationsprofi
also heute masken pflicht weg morgen
bundesregierung bei ihm auch im
halt der meinung bin ich auch alle
wenn dann jemand tatsächlich nicht so
schon mal vor zwei wochen hier an der
kommt die killer variante die leute
ministerium nach dem guten
stelle gesagt wenn ich die vier monate
zurücktreten geht ja nicht im kabinett
denken sich habt ihr noch alle in der
kommunikationsprofi hier gesagt dass man
viel ahnung von der materie hat oder
und das heißt als letzte frage werden
von karl lauterbach vergleiche mit den
wenn jemand das sozusagen nur als
aufgaben bisschen weniger talkshow bis
zwei jahren zwei jahren von jens spahn
wir das tun dann als erstes schmeißen
gedächtnisstütze nimmt ich stimme ihrem
wenn du jetzt heute könntest ja ich
hat sie entspannen mich ziemlich gut
eindruck zu der spd teil des kabinetts
sie mehr ministerium da gibt es ja viel
gemalt im wlan noch mal rein es absolut
meine der regen überall wurde überlaut
ist erbärmlich die grünen machen die
zu tun sobald man das haben wir doch in
lauterbach ist ja moment abgesehen von
der korona pandemie gesehen die
beste figur die fdp macht eine ganz gute
seiner rhetorik nicht mehr gefragt weil
die weil die leute sind ja relativ
entspannt die urlaubszeit gefragt ist
jetzt ein eine effiziente besetzung des
verteidigungsministeriums ob das mann
oder frau ist interessiert mich nicht
frau stark zimmermann wären als
vortragende figur glaube ich aber
vielleicht findet sich auch jemand
anders da müssen eltern würde auch was
ja an denen schon mal gedacht aber
blatter erlebnis wird er dann zum
friseur ich weise sollen
[Gelächter]